-I want to talk about
gun control and this moment
that's happening right now
after the tragedy at Parkland.
Do you feel that there
is actual pressure
on your colleagues
in the Senate?
Are these children actually
putting enough pressure on them
that change might happen here?
-I really do.
I was at that March,
and it is something
I'm never gonna forget.
For years,
as a former prosecutor,
we've worked with
law enforcement to try to get
some sensible gun legislation
in, for safety's sake.
We have then moved on.
That didn't work.
And then,
the moms, after Sandy Hook,
I remember them
sitting in my office,
telling the stories
of sitting in that fire station,
waiting as, one by one,
these kids would come in
to be reunited
with their parents,
and after a while,
those moms knew
they were never gonna see
their little kid again.
Hearing that story and thinking
they couldn't get
the legislation passed
with those stories,
and then finally,
Congress keeps trying,
we put forward bills
like I have on domestic abuse,
bills on background checks,
and, finally,
we are all gonna be bested
by a bunch of 16-year-olds.
So I am
really psyched about that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm glad you're psyched.
-I just -- I think that,
when a kid looks
at their parent
or their grandparent,
even in my state, where we have
a proud hunting tradition,
and they say,
"Look, hunting's fine,
but we don't understand why we
can't go to school and be safe."
And it's real hard
to say no to those kids.
-So I want to talk -- because
you do come from a rural state
that has a very
robust hunting community
and NRA members -- NRA members
who want more gun legislation.
And I always felt this moment
means, "Look, anyone --"
I think it's very fair to have
issue with NRA leadership.
I think that
there are NRA members
who have that membership
for a different reason.
They believe
in having a hunting rifle
or maybe even, you know,
a handgun in the home.
Are there NRA members
that are on --
or hold your position
on assault weapons
and on background checks,
and are they gonna be vocal
in this movement
that's happening?
-I mean, the polls show that
the majority of gun owners
want to see background checks.
You have the vast majority
of Americans
that want to see
better background checks.
You had the President
of the United States
at a meeting, where I sat
right across from him,
that said he wanted
to see background checks.
-But did you think that
he meant it when he said it?
-Yeah, well...
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna get to that
in a minute.
-Okay, good, yeah.
-Okay, so --
So there are just so many people
that want to see
these sensible gun legislation,
so I think it's got to happen.
But right now,
the NRA does have a sway
over so many of my colleagues.
It's about, of course,
the very false premise
that's put out there
that they're gonna just
take their guns away,
when, in fact,
there's no legislation
that's proposed to do that.
And then, secondly, the money,
and it's out there.
And it's money,
dark money from the outside.
-Now, you were at that meeting
with the President.
-Yes.
-That was very surreal to watch.
Because you don't usually see
cameras in those meetings
where you have members
of both parties
talking to the President
very openly
about different gun legislation.
He seemed very agreeable
to a lot
that was coming from
the left of that issue.
He seemed pro-background checks.
He even criticized
his colleagues
and said that
they were afraid of the NRA
and that they didn't
have to be afraid of the NRA
because he wasn't
beholden to the NRA.
That went away pretty quickly.
In that room, do you --
did you --
did your colleagues know
that this was show
and that nothing was being said
would have any permanence?
-Well, you want to hope so much
for those kids
and those moms I just described,
so you want to believe,
and he was actually listening.
He wasn't tweeting
anytime during the meeting.
[ Laughter ]
And he looked right across,
and he said not one,
not three times,
but nine times, I counted,
that he wanted to see
universal background checks.
And he said he endorsed my bill
when I explained to him
that 6,000 women have been
killed by their partners
with guns in an 11-year period.
And I said
that's more than we've lost
of our brave soldiers
in Iraq and Afghanistan.
And he said,
"Include Amy's piece in there."
And so the problem was,
we then went on,
and he got behind two good bills
but very narrow things
to improve background checks
and for safe schools.
He did that,
and that's all they've done.
And then, he met with the NRA
the next night,
and then we never heard
anything again
about universal
background checks
or anything again about
the domestic-violence bill.
And so we are not gonna give up,
and certainly those kids
aren't gonna let us give up.
-I am happy to hear that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You've been, obviously,
doing this for a while now.
You've had some success.
What was your first day like?
What was your first day
as a senator like?
-Well, my first day,
I will not forget.
I came from
a little different background
than some of the other Senators
and drove up there in my Saturn.
And we have
our first fancy lunch.
No longer made, I know.
We have our first fancy lunch.
And there we are
in the LBJ room --
this major portrait
of Lyndon Johnson above us.
And I go over and I grab
a salad and a cup of soup,
I bring it back.
Fancy place, ready to dive in.
And all of a sudden,
Patty Murray,
the only woman at the table
besides myself, jumps up,
runs around, grabs my arm,
and says, "Amy, you just took
the entire bowl
of thousand-island dressing,
and you're about to eat it."
[ Laughter ]
And I said,
"That's what we do in Minnesota.
We eat the thousand-island
dressing."
But what I learned that day is,
and I still
try to keep it as my mantra,
"Never forget
where you came from,
no matter what happens
in that place."
And if you want
to go into politics,
if we want more women
and younger people to do,
you're gonna confront obstacles,
you're gonna have
embarrassing moments,
but just don't give up.
-Oh, thank you so much
for being here.
Really appreciate it.
Senator Amy Klobuchar,
everybody.